you
it's like the fantasy you always have as
a kid everywhere is an amazing sharp
amazing character
it's about the humanity of it which just
makes the whole thing so real ready
Archer
well your hearts beating and you're
actually in this situation you get
something very genuine that you can the
plant
you'll actually compose shots that if we
were on a green screen set you just
wouldn't have known we're available
fresh is so high like we're making a
film that's right touching my favorite
movie of all time but then if you're too
respectful of it that you didn't do
anything new or different take a risk
then what are you bringing to the table
cool step down
I mean this is really where a film crew
like this really comes into their
about kids when you were four years old
grew up with Star Wars figures it's a
bit like just being that kid again
may the force be with us
hey youtubers is tronic happy Star Wars
Celebration so they dropped new rogue
one footage to set a whole bunch of
stuff about the movie so let's break it
down Darth Vader was in it they didn't
post the Darth Vader stuff but he is
definitely in the movie but this behind
the scenes is so amazing it just gives
you such a sense of the world that they
created while they were filming this
like there's the world that you
experience in the movie theater like you
just kind of transported there when
you're watching a Star Wars film because
of the music because everything's so
amazing but then you see a movie like
this and yeah there is some green screen
but it looks so much in the tone of the
classic Star Wars films in the way that
George Lucas made those with the use of
models real big sets now obviously that
caused a lot of problems for George
Lucas it was fun to watch the old
documentaries but it's just so tactile
so lived in it just looks so much more
real it just makes it a lot easier for
your adult brain to just set aside the
idea that this is a movie that people
are filming this isn't actually
happening the characters really
important stuff so obviously they
feature a lot of the characters in here
the biggest most awesome new thing that
I learned is that Mass Mickelson's
character is playing jyn erso father and
he is responsible for creating part of
the Death Star so let the way Mickelson
talks about his character he calls him
like the Oppenheimer of Star Wars
meaning that he probably created the
super laser if you're not familiar with
Oppenheimer he's the person in real life
who's credited with creating the atomic
bomb or bringing it to a workable state
there were a lot of people all over the
world Nazi scientists American
scientists trying to develop nuclear
technology he's just the one that's
credited with getting there first later
in life he seemed really remorseful
because this technology was used to
create death instead of create like so
many people died as a result of the
creation of the atomic bomb so now you
can understand how mass Mickelson's
character feels like maybe he was
creating an energy source that the
empire just turned into a laser maybe he
actually wasn't designing a laser
because he doesn't sound like a villain
just a really brilliant creative person
who has taken advantage of by the empire
so it was just really cool for him to
finally confirm that obviously we've met
jyn erso his daughter who's kind of the
point-of-view character of the film even
though it's an ensemble she's kind of
like the Luke Skywalker type character
the character that you follow through
the film Diego Luna is playing Captain
Cassie and and/or
works for rebel intelligence and he's
kind of like the glue that holds their
group together but they had to put their
ragtag team together to steal the plans
for the Death Star so naturally there's
a lot of friction inside the group he
said that he's kind of like the glue
that holds them together alan tudyk is
actually playing a droid this is
actually really exciting alan tudyk is
amazing whatever he does but his actual
designation is k2s oh and he says he's
like a repurposed Imperial droid but he
used to belong to the empire the rebel
stole him and reprogrammed him but the
way he described him he's kind of funny
he says that he's not your typical go
get the bags droid so he's not like a
courier he speaks his mind when he wants
to so you know the running joke of r2d2
having this really foul mouth but
because he only speaks in beeps you only
know that he said something really
inappropriate when c-3po bangs him on
the head
just imagine what r2d2 would be saying
if you could understand him that's what
Alan Tudyk droid character is going to
be like RISM EDD is playing Bodie Brook
he's kind of like a double agent working
for the rebels he said that you know
he's has this imperial patch on the side
of his arm so he basically explains that
people work for the Empire because they
need to earn money people work for evil
corporations in real life because they
need to support their families so his
day job is Empire but he's really
working with the rebel so he's kind of
like a double agent Donnie Yen badass
blind Jedi of the film you can actually
see him doing his stunts here in real
life like that's how much of a badass he
is but the way he talks about his
character is that he's just someone who
believes in the deep spirituality of the
force he calls himself a warrior so he's
not gonna be wielding a lightsaber but a
Jedi can use the Force to strengthen
common items so like his staff there can
be just as formidable as a lightsaber
when he needs it to be this is GN
weighing his characters named BAE's mal
busts he doesn't speak really great
English so he didn't speak a lot at
celebration he just said that he uses a
very very big gun he got a big laugh
from the crowd Forest Whitaker playing
Saul Guerrero he's actually a character
that debuted during the Clone Wars and
he has the narration during that
previous rogue one trailer you know what
will you become if they capture you the
way he talks about his character is that
he's kind of the leader of this rebel
band there's like a bunch of different
groups of rebels that come together to
form the rebel alliance his group is
just one of the more extreme factions
that are willing to
do anything to accomplish their goal so
you can see how he's like slightly
crossing the light like the Empire's bad
they do bad things they kill good people
but there are also people that work for
the Alliance that are just as hardcore
he's one of those people in ben
mendelsohn who's kind of like the big
bad of the film I know I said Darth
Vader's in the film but Ben Mendelsohn
is the real antagonist his name is
director or Seok Renny you could see the
white uniform he's wearing is kind of
inspired by the EU Grand Admiral white
uniform he just kind of been overseeing
the construction of the Death Star so he
actually made some really bold
statements saying that his villain is
way more inventive than previous Star
Wars villains so I'm actually really
curious to see what he ends up doing
like what it is that makes them so much
more clever than Grand Moff Tarkin
because that's kind of who he represents
in this film but if you guys didn't know
the movie is coming out December 16th so
expect Lucasfilm to post a whole bunch
of more cool stuff from the film in the
next couple of months but let me know
what you guys think about some of the
designs in this trailer I mean just like
scan back through this like you can
rewind in the video and just look at
some of the helmets some of the makeup
the sets that they built this definitely
looks like you're watching a documentary
of the making of the original trilogy
like George Lucas is walking around with
his beard and his flannel searched
somewhere in the background I always get
so excited when I watch stuff like this
but I know I said that I was gonna be
doing some Star Wars Episode 8 Mark
Hamill did this big panel they've
announced a few things that have been
going on with that so I'll do a video
for that on Saturday but James Gunn just
dropped a teaser for guardians of the
galaxy 2 that shows off the characters
and their full glory for the first time
so I'm gonna be doing a video for that
next so be sure to subscribe to get that
there'll be a couple more Star Wars
videos this weekend in the next week is
gonna be all Comic Con it's gonna be so
much fun while you guys wait for that
video to post you can click here for my
Thor Ragnarok teaser video and you can
click here for all my other guardians of
the galaxy to videos thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
and I'll see you guys tonight